do you ever get um you know kind of the
i'm sure you've had your share of of
negative influences maybe people that
don't like you in some way for your
music or your or this research do you
find any commonalities though in kinds
of the support or maybe the negative
attention that you get uh because you
know on the face of it yes there are
aspects of it but i would think naively
scientists pilots etc we'd be the most
interested but you made the interesting
point that it's part of culture and
people don't appreciate that science is
a form of culture too uh equal in every
respect in my opinion uh to arts and you
know and letters and so forth so do you
find commonality there tom just from the
two different careers that you've had
um i do i mean
you know it's funny like one of the one
of the when i was working with um
and when i was building relationships
with people before i knew jim that were
you know high-ranking former government
officials or military people and stuff i
remember i wanted to thank them um for
their time listening to me you know and
so
one way to thank them that i came up
with was in
the government kind of military
industrial complex world they all create
these challenge coins have you ever seen
the challenge coins where it's like you
got one here yeah i've got it you got
one there well for the people watching
it's like you know these little coins
that have like your platoon name on
there maybe the things you believe in
maybe it's the operation you were a part
of yeah here's one uh from my buddy in
afghanistan yeah they all make um um
there you go
so these little coins you bring them out
of bars and you owe each other drinks
depending on who's got a better coin or
whatever so i decided to make a
challenge point and i put on there the
vitruvian man which was
da vinci's you know
two arms two you know or forearms four
legs kind of thing but what that stood
for was art and science and what i
really liked about that and this all
comes full circle to your question was
um art and science to me was something
measurable with something that's
infinite you know it's consciousness and
zeros and ones to some degree but when
they come together um i think for the
longest time we've always separated
consciousness and things that we don't
understand and we put it in religion we
just go that's god's world so we can't
know that we can't measure that um yeah
there you go and um and so consciousness
in metaphysics and things we don't
understand was supernatural paranormal
um and it was in the realm of the old
testament or something you know um or
other religions um but the vitruvian man
this idea of bringing consciousness and
science or art and science together
because art is really just a stream of
consciousness you're making things up so
the question is is where are you getting
that you know you're you're some type of
antenna and you're pulling it from
consciousness in my view um so i use
this on the challenge point to say look
as an artist and as something that's
scientifically based here if we can
merge these together the future of
science i think is going to be once we
understand consciousness we take the the
realm of what used to be all religion or
something and we merge it with science
and now we got like this theory of
everything um so i wanted to say that my
my um
project was that it was an artist
working with things that are tangible
tangible and measurable and so i made
these challenge coins i put the
vitruvian man on there um and i gave
them to everybody and and um for me i
got the same rush
as being an artist but with this because
i really felt that i was
i was putting something together with a
point of view that people
really haven't been able to spend time
with or study or look at or notice
um
and it became kind of like the guiding
north star the light you know was the
merging of these two things um and it's
just been a hell of a lot of fun along
the way i believe it